Bonjour.
Comment ça va ?
Bien ?
Je m'appelle Vladimir Cagnolari et vous m'avez peut-être entendu de temps à autre sur rfi.
C'était entre 2001 et 2018.
Bref il y a une éternité !
Oui parce qu'entre temps, il m'est arrivé
deux trois bricoles et une aventure,
que je vous raconterai plus tard,
qui m'a propulsé dans le futur.
Oui vous m'avez bien entendu
dans le FUTUR !
Sur le calendrier juste à côté de moi,
il est écrit 2069
Comment ça va chez vous en 2019 ?
Il ya 50 ans...
En tout cas, ici, à A bidjan, ça va !
La cité a été cette année encore
élue ville la plus propre au Monde.
D'ailleurs l'eau de la lagune est si claire
que même les poissons n'arrivent
plus à se cacher.
ça râle chez les carpes croyez-moi...
Oui parce que figurez vous qu'aujourd'hui
on est capable de décrypter leur langage.
Au fait, je sais pas si vous savez,
mais ici on a du  courant en permanence
grâce aux lunes  artificielles qui ont été mises en orbite au dessus du pays,
et puis bien sûr on a jeté nos vieux téléphones
puisque on se parle maintenant sans même ouvrir la bouche
par télépathie, grâce à nos oreillettes
Greentooth.
Rassurez-vous, on peut aussi le débrancher en activant le mode "pensée"
Si je vous envoie ce message aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour vous faire
un dépliant vantant les mérites de ce qu'est devenu l'afrique.
Je voulais vous parler d'une idée, d'un courant de pensée important
qui n'est pas pour rien dans les changements que le continent a connu ces 50 dernières années.
Vers la fin du xxème siècle,
on l'a appelée...
Afrofuturisme !
Sans rêve pas d'avenir.
Et l'Afrofuturisme c'est notre capacité
à réinventer...Notre futur.
Que notre futur,
ne soit plus jamais uniquement
celui imaginé par les autres.
Celui qui n'est pas en capacité de se projeter dans le futur ne s'y trouvera pas !
En 2019, quand j'étais encore votre contemporain,
je m'étais intéressé à cette idée l'afrofuturisme.
Pour beaucoup d'entre nous, on en a entendu parler à la sortie du film "Black Panther".
Aujourd'hui, c'est devenu un classique,
mais pour l'époque, en amérique, en europe
et bien sûr en afrique,
c'était une petite révolution.
On retrouvait vraiment les costumes...On retrouvait l'image, la nature, le paysage.
Vraiment tout a été mis en avant, on a
vraiment valorisé l'afrique !
Ce qui n'est pas fait dans les autres films
malheureusement...
Et là je trouve que c'est un bon investissement...
Faut aller le voir !
Moi, c'est vraiment ça qui m'a marqué,
c'est la combinaison entre modernité et tradition !
Quand j'étais petit on jouait à être
superman.
Donc ça fait du bien, aujourd'hui,
de s'identifier à quelque chose qui nous ressemble
Qui ressemble à l'afrique !
Et oui les amis, c'est complètement dingue le succès
qu'a eu ce film le personnage black
panther existait depuis 1966 en bande
dessinée mais en 2018 c'était bien le
premier film de super-héros tourné dans
les studios d'hollywood et donc des
noirs étaient les personnages principaux
oui dans ces mêmes studios qui avait
passé à peu près un siècle a donné une
image bien peu valorisante de tout ce
qui venait d'afrique en 2018
le film des studios marvel rapporter
près d'un milliard et demi de dollars et
faisait un tabac en afrique
alors si je vous parle aujourd'hui de
plaque dentaire c'est que le film
emprunte est beaucoup d'éléments à ce
courant baptisé afro futur à l'époque
j'en avais parlé avec des tontons des
tontons pour qui ce film résonnait comme
une bonne nouvelle tient commençons par
binda ngazolo auteur et conteur
camerounais fanas de science fiction et
grand amoureux des cultures urbaines
retour en 2019
on s'était parlé au téléphone et tu
sortais de la projection de black
panther le film de marvel et d'été mais
alors enjaillé enthousiaste comme
rarement
j'étais bien entendu lettre raconte d'où
ce kit avait marqué ce qu'il n'avait
plus à ce point dans ce film c'est juste
que pour la première fois de ma chienne
de vie
je me suis enfin retrouver face à un
postulat qui consisterait à sublimer les
imaginaires d afrique en plus de
considérer les spiritualités d afrique
les traditions africaines
le style de vie des africains
l' architecture le stylisme et toutes
les choses que les africains
un mouvement depuis des millénaires
enfin dans un film on voit toutes ces
choses sublimes et d'abidjan à
johannesbourg en passant par naïrobi et
dakar le héros noirs de black panther
attiré les foules et en particulier les
jeunes
dans le film c'est ch à la suite à la
mort de son père qui monte sur le trône
du wakanda un petit pays situé au coeur
de l'afrique
doué d'un développement technologique
sans pareil grâce à l'utilisation d'un
minerai qu'il est seul à posséder le
vibranium mais ça seul les wakanda le
savent car le wakanda pour le reste du
monde demeure un pays pauvre et sous
développé xala donc le nouveau roi
enfile le costume de black panther
fabriqués avec vibranium maison qui
augmente ses pouvoirs et le rend quasi
invincible devant le film un autre
spectateur enthousiaste
souleymane bachir diagne en 2019 il
était professeur de philosophie à
l'université de columbia à new york
et c'est là bas qu'il a vu black panther
alors j'ai les vues
deux fois pour ce qui est de la toute
première fois j'étais très curieux de
voir ce phénomène qui était un film des
studios marvel donc les grands héros de
bande dessinée d'abord puis de des
cinémas ensuite ce que ça pouvait donner
effectivement quelque chose qui se
passait en afrique avec des langues
africaines qui intervenait ou alors de
l'anglais prononcé avec un accent qui
était un accent africain alors celui une
vision de la fiq évidemment tout à fait
positive on n'a pas l'habitude qu'au
cinéma ou même pas malheureusement dans
la presse aussi quand on parle de
l'afrique en général c'est que dans sa
demande mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'il ya
encore et là c'était une vision d'une
afrique hachuré d'elle-même et d'une
afrique également engagé dans la
technique et ça ça cassait complètement
un stéréotype qui voulait que l'afrique
soit le continent de l'imaginaire des
contes de l'émotion mais absolument pas
le continent de la maîtrise technique et
la petite est construit leur seul
royaume de wakanda autour de la maîtrise
technique et de la supériorité
technologique plus le rôle joué par les
femmes
donc ce double stéréotypes de l'afrique
un étranger d'une certaine manière à la
technique et des femmes étrangères
également aux sciences et aux techniques
c'est ce look stéréotypes qui était
cassée par ce film black panther et ça
ça m'avait beaucoup intéressé parce
qu'effectivement je crois que c'est une
manière de capturer un moment qui est
réel en afrique c'est pas simplement
dans une sorte de compensation
imaginaire si vous voulez mais ça me
semble ce film sont capturées quelque
chose qui est réel aujourd'hui en
afrique qui fait que ce continent
effectivement est en train de basculer
et j'ai des trucs super rapport très
grand frère là ce sont les dispositifs
comme pour la corée
ils ont une portée limitée et ils sont
équipés d'un système d'audio
surveillance autonome regard ça une
commande à distance en perles qui moyo
amélioré pour un faire passer
directement avec ma carte
ce que vous me dites monsieur gagne là
c'est que même si c'est une fiction même
si on est dans l'imaginaire voir la
mythologie en fait s'il ya des choses
très précises qui sont conformes à un
état actuel des choses même s'il est en
encore en friche oui absolument
ce que ce que les prospectivistes
appelle des germes des changements des
germes le changement aujourd'hui en
afrique sont très visibles il faut pas
il faut pas tomber dans l'excès inverse
évidemment une espèce d'optimisme des
vivants mais je vous donne simplement un
exemple très précieux pour vous montrer
en quoi ce film se l'accordent quand
même à des choses qui sont sur le
terrain réel
il y a eu beaucoup de réflexions sur
l'investissement des jeunes dans les
technologies de la communication et
qu'en particulier aussi toujours le
cadre et rubina et ruby est devenu un
point sur la casse de la civilisation
digitale qui ne correspond absolument
pas au poids économique du kenya mais
qui en revanche dit quelque chose de la
créativité des jeunes kenyans qui ont
transformé le cet outil banal qui est le
téléphone portable en mode de paiement
des choses comme ça c'était ça indique
ces deux choses d'abord que il y à une
application des technologies aux
problèmes qui sont les problèmes de
l'afrique parce qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de circulation de l'argent
il n'y a pas suffisamment de
bancarisation
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas de compte en
banque et bien ce problème en utilisant
le téléphone portable et ça c'était un
aspect important
le deuxième aspect important aussi dans
ce cas là c'est de dire contre l'idée
selon laquelle il n'y a pas de la kossi
technologique que pour arriver à un
certain niveau de sophistication
technologique il faut déjà être passer
par des étapes en théorie cela ces
jeunes créatifs
monde que s'il faut et qu' il suffit de
voir les problèmes colonna est de dire
on va mettre sur ces problèmes là on va
mettre ce qui à notre disposition sur le
plan technologique en adaptant ses
technologies là et ça c'était également
un message porteur d'avenir parce qu'on
a cette image omniprésente de jeunes
africains qui ont l'impression que leur
avenir est forcément hors du continent
et qui se noie dans la méditerranée
c'est malheureusement une image qui est
là et qui nous pourrons encore quelques
temps mais c'est bon d'avoir de le
recruter
cette image également d'une jeunesse qui
est là qui à tous les problèmes du monde
ils qui s'est dit et bien ces problèmes
résolvez les et pour les résoudre
regardons les technologies et adaptons
les à ces problèmes qui sont les nôtres
en 2019 tout le monde disait que
l'afrique est un continent d'avenir et
tous les africains attendaient que cette
prophétie se matérialisent enfin oui
c'est vrai est ce qu'on mange l'avenir
en tout cas dans black panther le
wakanda incarne un idéal celui d'une
afrique indépendante souveraine et qui
maîtrise son développement sans avoir
besoin de l'aide des autres
oui parce qu'on le sait bien la main qui
reçoit est toujours en dessous de celles
qui donnent surtout le wakanda avec son
bouclier qui le rend invisible aux
intrus ces vaisseaux sophistiqué et
toutes ces innovations technologiques
comme celle que met au point chaud ribes
la soeur du roi tchalla le wakanda high
tech donc ne restent pas moins enracinée
dans ses traditions le réalisateur afro
américains ryan couleurs à truffer le
film de symboles piocher ça et là dans
les civilisations africaines les
salutations ougandaise par exemple bras
croisés sur le torse renvoie à l'egypte
pharaonique les costumes des tribus du
wakanda rappelle tour à tour les massaï
du kenya à les himbas de namibie les
touareg les peuls où les moursi
l'ethiopie tout ça un peu pêle mêle
c'est vrai mais avec décidé d'incarner
la diversité culturelle du continent
il y a aussi les tatouages
dans le film c'est fameux codes barres
luminescents gravé sous les lèvres qui
permettent aux attentes des de se
reconnaître
de quoi renvoyer là aussi aux marques
corporelles et autres scarifications qui
fonctionnait en afrique comme des cartes
d'identité bref le wakanda et
ultramoderne et en même temps ne renonce
pas à la culture que les ancêtres ont
légué souleymane bachir diagne
prenons un exemple précis un
dénominateur commun les religions
africaines
encore une fois les ailes sont très
différentes entre elles parce que c'est
un côté là et très divers mais c'est
vrai qu'il y à un dénominateur commun
des religions africaines qui est une
place spéciale réservée aux ancêtres ce
qu'on a appelé le sistership en anglais
le culte des ancêtres qui c'est une
manière un peu rapide d'expliquer cela
mais il ya cette idée que les ancêtres
qui sont partis d'une certaine façon
continue agir au bénéfice de la
communauté qu'ils ont un mode de
présence dans la communauté et une
action bienfaisante pourvu que la
communauté se souviennent de donc d'où
l'idée qui on le rend culte mais c'est
plus si vous avez la mémoire de nous en
retour vous bénéficiez de la force
bienveillante que nous avons insufflé
dans la communauté
et bien cette croyance traditionnel qui
est au coeur des religions
traditionnelles africaines
quelques séries des gens aient disparu
ou sont en voie de disparition
devant
les gens universaliste abrahamiques de
son fils yanis mme et l'islam
on voyait dans ce film une forme de
nationalisation de cela parce que notre
jeune héros qui se retrouve comme en
rêve au milieu des ancêtres
et qui puisent fort sous la dent c'est
une manière très hollywoodienne de
retravailler ce mythe mais justement
d'en faire un mythe qui est un parfait
de réseaux l'ancien parfaite continuité
avec cette culture de la technologie
tehua quang ninh dans le caucase a eu
lien en des condéens des rats des babas
bomback broc
bush al haouz luxe elle est là ou pas
econgas découpe on dit ça du coup
prêtresse ou chez les apprête à la noix
norbert je ne te parle pas de ça
je ne suis pas encore prêt à vivre
centre un père qui n'a pas préparé ses
enfants à son décès a failli à ses
devoirs
crois tu que j'ai failli jamais
c'est une image de l'afrique qui est
présenté dans black panther puisque l'on
wakanda y situer là bas sur le continent
un pays à l'autre les difficile de
définir les contours qui emprunte à
beaucoup de pays beaucoup de cultures
africaines mais c'était aussi une vision
futuriste de l'afrique mais américaine
ah oui ça c'est effectivement le olivier
dc et marvel studios y sont c'est à dire
que c'est la projection de la vision
américaine de la fiq à la fois
américaine général mais les allemands
africaine américaine parce que il faut
bien se rendre compte que les africains
américains comme on dit en américain où
les afro américains comme nous disons
que nous parlons français pour eux mêmes
dans leur tête un certain imaginaire
africains une histoire une carte de
l'afrique même qui n'est pas la carte
réelle de la fille c'est à dire que
l'africain américain verra justement ces
trafics un petit peu idéalisée l'egypte
en ciel d'abord donc il y aura une
insistant sur le fait que l'egypte
ancienne et d'une civilisation africaine
les mines du zimbabwe lempire du mali
dans ses côtés légendaire le côté
légendaire de soundiata keïta voilà
c'est cette afrique là on a l'impression
que c'est une carte rectrice y autour de
quelques grandes point qu'ils soient des
points saillants et les points un peu
brillant de l'histoire africaine
évidemment c'est cette image là que le
film autoproduit finalement c'est le
résultat d'une histoire particulière
aussi celle des afro américains mais
aussi des peuples de la diaspora parce
qu'on les a privés cette histoire et
pire on a souvent et olives ou dit a
bien contribué à insuffler cette idée
que l'afrique est un continent sauvage
au point de créer des complexes
ce qu'on trouve d'ailleurs aussi en
afrique avec le blanchissement de la
peau et autres mais cette vision
mythique
elle a un peu en réaction à tout se
passait ce passif oui absolument et
d'une certaine façon
un autre effet du ce de ses films c'est
de manifester précisément une forme de
réappropriation par la diaspora de
l'afrique et de son africanité à elle
ses diasporas
parce qu'effectivement le côté le plus
pervers racisme et du colonialisme
savait était de d'établir parmi les
africains eux-mêmes continentaux et
africains de la diaspora une espèce de
hiérarchie qui faisait que quand on
était de la diaspora on estimé qu'on
avait d'une certaine façon échapper à la
fiscalité mais ça monte en quoi les
sociétés peuvent être malades des
stéréotypes qui sont projetés sur elle
et la manière dont les africains de la
diaspora ne tenait absolument pas et
tous les africains ne pas être confondus
surtout avec les africains
ça a été la maladie si vous voulez de
beaucoup hélas ce que ce film me disais
aussi de l'imaginaire qui s'est projeté
maintenant sur le continent c'était un
désir d'afrique de la part des africains
de la casse toi et c'est pas un hasard
c'est justement dans les dernières
années le monde
african americans est imposé c'est aussi
cette réappropriation l'a absolument
donc après avoir été appelé ni rose puis
black's
trouvez africaine américaine c'était une
manière effectivement de créer un trait
guillon sans jeu de mot avec le
continent et de réclamer son
appartenance au continent africain
ah oui c'est sûr black panther utilisent
des références et des thèmes qui renvoie
l'histoire des noirs américains et à
leurs luttes d'émancipation arraché à
l'afrique coupés de leurs racines
citoyens de seconde zone voire pas
citoyen du tout pendant la ségrégation
aux états unis ils ont été fouillés dans
l'histoire dans les mythes dans tout ce
qu'il pouvait trouver sur les
civilisations africaines pour y puiser
des éléments qu'ils se sont appropriés
une manière de se re construire
eux-mêmes pour pouvoir bâtir un futur
l'afro futurisme dérives de cette
recherche
s'interroger sur son identité liée à
l'afrique et s'imaginer un futur
différent de celui que laisse entrevoir
le présent plutôt sombre afro futurisme
le mot même date du début des années 90
et provient d'un critique américain
blanc marc déry qui a compris en tout
cas que cette quête concerné nombre
d'artistes afro-américains au point de
devenir une tendance un cousin mais
alors on peut se demander en quoi cet
afro futurisme concernent des africains
qui eux vivent sur le continent qui
n'ont pas été forcés à traverser
l'atlantique et qui sont a priori rester
plus proche de leur culture
en gros si la préfecture isme est né non
les diasporas en quête de racines
africaines
est-ce qu'il a un sens en afrique la
parole est au vieux lion binda ngazolo
un jour un aigle je fais une
communication au moment d'une
communication à l'école des arts
dramatiques à abidjan j'ai les étudiants
devant moi et j'ai introduit en disant
quand nous étudions les aga matic
nous étudions le théâtre classique c'est
une bonne chose
maintenant que savez-vous de nos
classiques en silence non j'ai les
stimule un peu j'ai dû manquer bombe
attendent à tour de rôle prenons par
exemple le conte le premier tour le rôle
que savez vous du compte des machines à
abidjan
moi mes parents ne m'ont pas dit de
comptes
non moi je connais pas et contes
africains au suivant moi j'ai découvert
les comptes à travers les fables de la
fontaine vont moins au troisième de ces
messieurs
oui moi je prends même disait des
comptes quand j'étais enfant et au
village d un génial vous en avez gardé
en mémoire
mais non pourquoi ça me sert à amiens il
ya un motivés qui m m les ouïes m est ce
que vous trouvez pas que les contes
africains c'est obsolète
vous avez parlé gros france est obsolète
n'est ce pas ainsi donc à période
historique égale le théâtre classique
que vous étudié à l'école d'art
dramatique
abidjan n'est pas obsolète ce qui est
obsolète c'est ce qui vient de tes
ancêtres vrai comment on est mal barré
ce n'est pas possible d'aller enrichir
les autres en allant leur ça c'est la
propre histoire qu'ils connaissent mieux
que nous il faut que nous venions avec
notre part donc voilà je ne parle pas là
n'a faut descendre américain combat dire
qu'ils ont été à l'aîné est détaché
dépossédé de même je parle là d'urbain
africain ils sont aussi déconnecté que
n'importe quel autre jeune africain sur
la planète
nous avons été configuré pour
l'essentiel à nous de considérer le même
et à déconsidérer puisqu'il vient de
nous y compris nos imaginaires hors dons
si nous partons du présupposé du
postulat que c'est notre capacité à
imaginer le monde de demain qui va
garantir notre survie
demain celui qui n'est pas en capacité
de se projeter dans le futur ici pour
voir parce que comme je dis l'équipement
est le seul animal qui a attrapé le
virus de la pensée il pense tellement
qu'il a foutu un bordel indescriptible
il va finir par tuer la terre
sa propre mère et comme dans sa vie est
rattachée à la terre mère puisque
lui-même vient de la terre mère il
commence à monter des plantes pour voir
s'il n'y a pas une autre carte dans
l'espace il va pouvoir habiter voilà
voilà à quoi sert l'anticipation
parce que quand la conquête de l'espace
sener autre chose pour les enfoirés qui
nous met dans la situation où nous
pouvons la houle à notre belle planète
est en train de mourir tranquillement de
sa belle mort y réfléchissent donc à
comment ils vont faire pour se tirer
d'affaires et ça ce sont des postulats
que des auteurs de science fiction avait
déjà projeté changement de décor paris
sina tout ça cas de rfi passionné par ce
sujet de la trop futurisme participer à
un atelier d'écriture laissant libre
cours à l'imagination des jeunes femmes
qui étaient là elles se projetait en
il ya quatorze ans pour vous dans 36 ans
et pour ouvrir la séance
maïwenn highway ci qui a fondé un
collectif d'artistes d'auteur et
d'autriche baptisé plax tous deux futurs
collectifs qui oeuvrent jeux située à
quelque part à une vision alternative
durable et décomplexée du monde et ses
dimensions afro connexes pire elle s'en
est compliqué comme ça mais elle ne
quittera dans un prochain épisode là
puisqu'on parle de black panther et bien
sûr son point de vue
et autant vous le dire elle n'a pas du
tout aimé
l'acteur utilise une esthétique afro
futuriste qui pour moi est somme toute
minime
on va finalement essayé de travailler
les motifs africains va essayer de
trouver des formes organiques qui sont
identifiés comme étant de provenances
africaine avec somme toute comme une
sorte de gros mélange blu ray je sais
toujours pas ce que c'est que
l'esthétique african 54 pays dans l'ue a
bon je ne sais pas mais surtout ce qui
moi me dérange avec black panthers
c'est que l'espace même dans lequel se
crée et se constitue
l'oeuvre de marvel n'est pas un frau
futuriste marvel n'est pas un profil sur
un banc un auteur de science-fiction
blanc des années 70 qui travaillent à
l'hégémonie américaine
et surtout ce qui est gênant règle un
compteur franchement je te donne deux
exemples
c'est un film qui travaille à partir
d'un rapport d'exploitation
enfin ce qui fait la force de wakanda
c'est continuer à travailler et à puiser
dans les terres désolées
enfin gilbert étrange un même les
personnages dit féministe a pour moi non
ce sont des personnages masculins
incarné par des femmes j'aurais voulu
voir de type de schéma une femme n'a pas
que le choix entre être caricaturées
lmnp soit la mer reine mère au foyer
soit la guerrière soit la geekette ce
qui moi me dérange avec black panthers
en faire une sorte de manifeste afro
futuriste d'une s'est arrêté là
professionnalisme et à nouveau pour mal
à progresser quelque chose qui est une
progresse
cette idée de méthodologie qui se
construit tout le temps qui se défait
mais surtout le futur présenté par black
panthers - angoisse terriblement
en fait j'ai l'impression que c'est le
futur capitaliste d'aujourd'hui avec des
noirs en charge la fin du film se
termine quand même par un moment
d'adoubement auprès des espèces d'eau du
factice et la dernière phrase du film
c'est quand même qu'est ce que ces
petits africains ont ce petit berger ont
à offrir au monde soit un peu
problématique de finir le film par ce
type de phrase
font absolument trouver le moyen de
prendre soin de notre prochain comme si
nous ne formions qu'une seule et unique
tribu sauf votre respect pour un cha là
qu'est ce qu'une nation d'éleveurs
pourrait bien offrir au reste du monde
rien de tel qu'un bon pour marquer son
agacement ou sa désapprobation si
quelqu'un fait nouveau fonds tentant et
oui c'est vrai c'est la dernière phrase
du film mais là on comprend que celui
qui pose cette question ne connaît rien
à rien et surtout rien au rwanda tout le
petit sourire ironique du roi tchalla
alors oui c'est vrai le modèle one day
ne révolutionne pas tous en tout cas pas
l'ordre mondial
mais ça ne m'empêche pas de développer
un discours politique et notamment sur
les rapports de domination dort sud qui
se retrouvent à verser le simple fait
que les pays exploite lui même ses
ressources c'est déjà le contre pied de
tout ce qui existait en 2019 en afrique
puisque les matières premières à de
rares exceptions près et est exploitée
par d'autres occidentaux ou asiatiques
idem pour cette séquence où qu'ils m'ont
girl le cousin de tshala qui a grandi
dans les ghettos noirs américains
décident de s'emparer dans un musée
londonien d'un objets rituels qui
contient deux vibranium et qui provient
du wakanda pas besoin d'en rajouter
là encore pour comprendre la critique du
pillage des objets cultuels africains
qui garnissent les musées occidentaux
dans le mythe du wakanda il ya aussi
cette image d'une afrique qui n'aurait
pas subi l'esclavagé ni la colonisation
effectivement voir qu'on n'a jamais été
colonisé puisque précisément étant donné
sa propre puissance il c'est un
territoire qui n'a jamais pu être
colonisé où vous avez plusieurs choses à
la fois une sorte d vocation de se taire
un peu mythique qui est l'équipe i les
tipis et cet air qui n'a jamais été
colonisé et d'ailleurs vous voyez bien
l'importance que l'équipe eut une équipe
i meetic a eu dans le rastafarisme par
exemple en jamaïque et dans le nouveau
monde comment l'imaginer ce territoire
jamais conquis à fonctionner et ouakka
cultive ce même phénomène qu aurait été
notre propre trajectoire s'il n'y avait
pas eu cette interférence
massive et désastreuse qu'a été la
colonisation
mais par ailleurs il y à aussi je crois
une projection futuriste donc c'est à la
fois une sorte de réécriture du passé
mais c'est de l'écriture du passé et
fait aussi pour une écriture du futur
c'est pas simplement quelque chose de
mort né ou on dit que ce lyon nous
devenus si c'est aussi cette manière de
dire quel avenir fois ci sont
aujourd'hui pour nous et c'est ça me
semble logique qui est important
maintenant le film est ce que c'est
précisément là un peu les constantes
même si sous ce vocable vous rassemble
beaucoup de choses finalement assez
disparate mais de ce qu'on a appelé en
tout cas au départ
l'afro futurisme voilà je crois que
c'est un film qui donne corps à et vous
avez raison de dire que ce qu'on a
appelé la flf utilisent ces sites à
disparaître parce qu'on se demande quoi
mettre là-dedans parce que mon pauvre tu
m finalement l'excellent roman de mon
ami imaginons les étages il a fait que
la file devenu un pays puissant etc
c'est de la fois futurisme de ce point
de vue là et je crois que ces films aura
eu le mérite de décor à la fois
futurisme désormais je crois quand on va
utiliser ce concept quand on va en
parler
il saisit mal de ses films s'imposeront
et canaliseront en quelque sorte ce que
l'on essaye de dire de manière plus
sérieuse en considérant la flo futurisme
cette manière que la fille d'aujourd'hui
à de se projeter dans un avenir dans son
avenir
une manière de dire que l'avenir c'est
ce qu'elle va faire
et évidemment il faut laisser galoper
l'imagination c'est de ces deux
principes non seulement du futurisme si
actuellement le principe la prospective
une bonne perspective c'est pas
simplement prolonger mathématiquement
des tendances aujourd'hui c'est
également un moment donné dit répond
donc ce mélange de rêve
et de et de pragmatisme et ça c'est une
dimension importante de ce film au chili
s'en relève pas d'avenir et la faux culs
lindsay notre capacité à réinventer
notre futur que notre futur ne soit plus
jamais uniquement celui imaginé par les
autres et c'est ça que black panther
nous t'aimons tu payes et vous vous avez
des choses à nous raconter
racontez vos voilà depuis ses propos
tenus en 2019
les choses ont changé ça je vous en
reparlerai parce que là maintenant il
faut que j'y aille oui j'ai rendez-vous
dans quinze secondes dans un space
maquis endroit où l'on cause dans ce
marché en bois en apesanteur
alors c'est sûr on va parler des
élections qui viennent d'ailleurs
les choses ont évolué si vous savez
depuis 2030 plus personne ne peut rester
au pouvoir plus de deux mandats
on a inventé un bracelet électronique
mais sur le poignet du président et qui
l'empêchent au dernier jour de son
mandat fin dès qu'il a fini quoi de
s'approcher même de la présidence
eh ouais fallait y penser bon je vois
fils et je coupe la transmission